I had this really, really, really great childhood. I grew up in a
wonderful home with both my parents and they gave me every
single thing I could ever imagine. It was, you know, really elaborate
holidays and great
vacations. And just everything, they wanted to expose me to the world. I mean they
had me out there, uh, showing horses. You know,
riding - horseback riding.
I was the only brother at the stable, out there riding a horse. That's what I was doing when I
was ten years old. They wanted to make sure that I knew the world was my oyster
and I could be or do anything I wanted. It was a really really nice perfect
upbringing and, you know, they had a plan in mind when they gave me this, uh, upbringing,
and that plan was for me to go to college, then go to law school and go off and get
a really good job and the really good job in my parents' mind was
for me to be president of the United States. Um, that's right - the guy who
was Barack Obama before he was Barack Obama is standing here before you right now.
I was supposed to be the first black president of the United States. That was the
plan. And so I bought in this plan, it was a good plan, right,  who doesn't want to be president.
So I went off to
college, um, um, majored in international affairs, went off to law
school after that and graduated from law school and then had this opportunity
to run, uh, an inner city school in the city of Chicago and while
being an educator or taking that role wasn't really part of the plan,
I realized that it could really help me. When
I started pursuing this political career. I mean who's not going to vote for
the guy
who stands there in the ad with his hands on his hips looking like Superman, in front of
a classroom of kids.  You know -
You know - "Vote Tim McCain - He changes the world.  He educates kids."
So I figured OK. I'll take this job and, um, you know, maybe it'll
you know lead me to some other things that follow along with the plan.
One day I was walking into the school, it was pretty early,
around 7, 7:30 in the morning and I, uh, unlocked the door and there
was a kid sitting outside waiting to get in. His name was Keith.
I, I said you know, "What are you doing?" He's like, "Oh, I'm, you know, working here painting during the summer."
Okay, so, come on in. And Keith certainly was painting with a bunch
of the other students at the school that summer. Uh, he would stay really late.
The next day he showed up very early, stayed really
late and the summer eventually melted into the school year and
Keith was still coming to school really really early and staying at school really really late and I just figured
Okay this guy just you know likes
school, um. Although I didn't understand how anyone could like school that much.
But I started kind of keeping an eye on him, you know, because there was something up with
this, with this young man. And eventually
he started talking to me and having conversation. Throughout the course of the day, he'd stop by my office and say "what
was up", you know, he talked to me after school and then he started, you know,
doing things like asking me if he could borrow a couple
bucks and I'd give him the money. I really didn't pay much attention to the reasons
why he needed the money. In fact I really wasn't all that interested in knowing because I didn't really
didn't really want to, you know,  know that much. Right? I just, here's the money. You know you stay in
your world, it's cool, I'm in
mine. You go right ahead with your business. Step by step
though, you know, he started asking for more money, more frequently,
he started hanging out in my office a bit more, he started talking to me more coming out of his shell and I
was coming out of my shell a bit with
him. And one day I asked him, you know, what did he need this money for? And he said, oh I've gotta go do my laundry.
And I thought, this kid's lying to me. What, what, you know, fifteen year old has to go
and do his laundry, needs money, to go and do his laundry? Um, but
I gave him the money anyway and you know just said okay, you know, go do what you have to do. One night I got a
call from Keith, um, and he was in
hysterics and, um, he asked me if I would help him. If I'd
get him from his house
house. And I said "sure, you know, what's what's going on what's wrong" and he said, "my mom just died."
So I go over to his house, and it's not a house, it's
an apartment over a liquor store.
And I walk in and it's pitch black in the apartment, just the light from the streetlamps coming in
the window. And I see...from that light I
see garbage
bags. Some  bags with garbage in them and other bags with his
stuff and I'm...no lights, not because he had turned off the lights
because the electricity was
off. There was no power in this apartment and it was cold.
And he was
just in hysterics because his mother had just died. She had been battling, unbeknownst
to me, drug addiction. And she lost that battle. And the
drugs won and she died and so we grabbed Keith's stuff in the garbage bags,
put them in my car
and then I was faced with "well, where do we go?"
So I said to him, you know, "you got a friend you can stay with?", and he
said sure" and we drop him off at a friend's house and I went back home to
my house. Um, the next day, Keith was at
school.
And, we talked and tried to work through where he was going to live and we
found another place for him to stay. Temporarily.
And then, you know, I started getting closer to Keith, we started talking more... obviously this kind of experience,
you know, brings people together. And so you know, we would, you know, go out - I'd take him out to eat after
school or we would go to the movies or we'd go to a basketball game or something
you know like that. And every time after
after, we'd, you know, go to dinner or go to the game, I would drop him
off at someone else's house and I would go home to mine.
One
day Keith and I were sitting in the car after we had gone out or something and
we were trying to work through where he was going to go and you know, he just looked
at me and he said, "Why can't I just live with you?
Why can't you be my dad?"
At that moment I thought,
Are you crazy? Of course you can't live with me!
Of course I can't be your
dad. You don't fit into this plan. I'm going to be the first black president of the United
States. You can't move in with me. I had
put Keith in this box. This box that said: 'Poor Black Boy Inside - Handle With
inside handle with care." And I put that box far away from me.
I didn't allow myself to get close to that
box, to get close to Keith. All of that went through my
head in a matter of seconds. Quite literally. And
when I came out of this kind of fog and he was still sitting there in the car
looking at
me, asking if he could live with
me, asking if I could be his dad. And I looked at him. And
I said "yes. Yes, you
can live with me. Yes, I will be your dad." And at
that moment,
I changed. I felt right.
I just felt right
right. Now...what I
should have felt was terrified. Because when Keith
moved into my house... It wasn't like, you know, one
elephant coming through - it was a herd of elephants.
He took over. As a, as a matter of fact, when I met Keith and he moved
in I had a full head of
hair. We're talking giant afro. From the sixties, seventies afro. You know what
I'm saying? He ran it all away. It was really really
really hard, living with him. He had been
used to living by himself. Living on his own. I had been used to living by myself.
Living on my own.
He, while living a life that was like an adult as a child,
he all of a sudden had an opportunity to be a kid again. And I
had lived this life like a kid with a bank account and all of a sudden I
had to be an adult.
Keith
and I managed to make it
through our time living together. He calls
me dad. I refer to him as my son.
He graduated from high school and he went on to
Georgetown University, my alma mater.
He graduated from Georgetown. Moved back home to
Chicago and right now, at this very moment, he works
with me in a network of charter public high schools that I started
called Urban Prep. He's a teacher. I started Urban Prep
because I wanted to make sure that all the Keiths in the world were taken care of.
He works at Urban Prep because he wants to be a part of changing lives
like his life was changed. When Keith and I live together
to this very day, what I wanted to do was make sure that he had a life that was
filled with love.
The life I had when I was growing up.
People always say to me.... Oh,Tim, you changed Keith's life.
And I say to them, "he changed mine."
As we walked down
that road of him going from being a boy
to becoming a man. While I was helping him grow, from boyhood to manhood,
he was helping me grow. He was helping me become a better
man. A
little while ago I got a text message from Keith.
And the text message read, "Our family's at the basketball game.
Where are you? You should be here."
And I smiled because Keith was berating me. And
then I got a little teary because as I looked down at that text message
I realized that Keith
written: Our Family. Our family.
Thank you.
you.